[Musique]
le département l'État et l'Agence
française de développement s'engage sur
deux nouvelles conventions la feuille de
route grand âge et le développement des
réseaux d'irrigations dans les Hauts 500
000 euros financeront les études visant
à développer les offres de services
d'hébergement et le maintien à domicile
des personnes âgées on le sait le nombre
de personnes âgées de plus de 60 ans va
doubler dans les 20 prochaines années et
ce qui est important pour nous c'est
d'accompagner ce mouvement cette
transition démographique et nous devons
le faire et nous le faisons en lien bien
évidemment avec le préfet de la Réunion
mais aussi l'ARS l'agence de régionale
de santé et nous avons établi un plan
mais pour pouvoir accélérer la mise en
oeuvre de ce plan ben on a besoin de
financement déterminer la stratégie du
département pour faire face
à l'accélération de vieillissement de la
population et à ne pas prendre le choc à
anticiper en tout cas ce choc pour
[Musique]